there are moments in the donbass when
normality intrudes
here a medical student called skiff
rediscovers his limbs before a shift at
an ad hoc ambulance base
his colleague van damme finds a
different way to unwind pounding on a
tree in the garden
every ambulance needs a bodyguard here
and it's his job to keep the rescuers
safe
do you feel secure ambulances are
supposed to be
protected they're supposed to be safe
absolutely
despite the danger they run to the van
and the first call comes in
it's their job to pick up injured
soldiers and the ukrainians are
suffering heavy casualties
officials say 500 troops are injured
every day as the russians batter their
way into the donbass
one hour later they came back up the
drive and we caught up with them at the
end of their trip
good
good job a typical emergency said skiff
their patient hit by shrapnel from
artillery fire that said but like always
was it artillery or was it shooting
artillery it was artillery
there is some weariness here although
the 26 year old has just started his
career
he wants to be a plastic surgeon but the
war has changed his life
when we have a
leg amputation or hand imputation or big
big injury
of
tours
after so
blood on the floor blood on the wall all
my clothes and blood
i can show you my all my clothes now
that's like a first world war when
soldiers staying on
on the positions and just waiting off
artillery
within a few minutes they were back on
the road
more soldiers had been hit by artillery
fire and they needed treatment and
transport from the front line
we waited under trees for the troops to
turn up
but the medics thought we were being
watched
we've been told to get off the road and
to hide under these trees because there
are russian drones
above us and it goes to show nothing is
off limits
in this war everybody
everyone is a target
van damme kept watch as the crew looked
on and the casualties eventually arrived
a soldier with multiple shrapnel wounds
was ushered inside
but they knew their medical staging post
was unsafe
they may have been mortars or a large
caliber weapon but it was clear this was
no place to hang around
okay let's go much more serious person
here on the right just yes
[Music]
they stabilized the soldier in the back
of their van and sped to the local
hospital
in a few weeks they think he'll probably
be back at the front
it's what ukrainians expect and it's
what they desperately need
john sparks sky news in eastern ukraine